ALAN VIVERETTE: Good
morning, everyone,
and welcome to "Themes
and Styles Demystified."
I'm Alan Viverette.
I'm a tech lead on
the UI Toolkit team
and the engineer responsible
for the Material themes.
CHRIS BANES: Hi,
I'm Chris Banes,
an engineer on the
Developer Relations team.
I also work on AppCompat, so
I deal with themes and styles
quite a lot.
So it's great to see so
many faces in front of me,
especially sunburned
ones, because it's
been hot here in Mountain
View over the past day or two.
So it's 9:00 AM here.
And I can see quite a few
tired faces in front of me.
So I thought I'd
start with a quiz.
So the first question I've got.
In what Android version
did Theme.Holo appear?
Right, so Android Eclair?
Hands up.
Honeycomb?
Oh, you're too clever.
That's an easy one.
How about the
DarkActionBar variant?
Honeycomb?
Honeycomb 3.2?
A few.
ICS?
Eh.
Third one, how did
selectableItemBackground
change KitKat?
Did it change to ripple?
Uh, one.
It changed to monochrome.
I've pressed the
wrong button there.
Don't worry.
I've got a fourth.
In what version can you use
Android:foreground on a View?
Android 1.0?
Oh, I got a few.
ICS?
A few again.
How about Marshmallow?
Ah, see, this is
my trick question.
So you can actually use
Foreground on Frame Layout
from API 1.
But we only actually added
it and moved it up to View
on Marshmallow.
So that's why it's trick.
Anyway, hope you're awake now.
So this talk is all
about themes and styles.
And we've realized
recently that there aren't
that many people who know it.
It's quite a dense topic.
And there's lots of little
intricacies into it all.
So we thought we'd
write these talks
and try and give everyone
like a level playing field.
So before we actually go
into the guts of it all,
I thought we'd take a
quick refresher course
and see what they actually are.
So technically,
themes and styles
are exactly the same thing.
Internally, they're both
declared using the style tag.
So in your resources,
you create your styles.
And you'll notice that when
you actually create a theme,
you're still using
the style tag.
The only difference between
them is how you use them
in your application.
And we'll talk more
about that later.
So at the simplest,
styles and themes--
because they're the same thing--
are just key-value stores.
So here we've got a
very, very simple style.
And you'll notice that the
actual key is the attribute,
so android:background
in this instance.
And then the value
is color blue.
So we've just mentioned
the word attributes there.
And they're the key to what
themes and styles are all
about.
Now let's take a quick look
at what they actually are
and how they work.
So as we mentioned,
attributes are just keys.
They're declared in
the Android framework
and also in your apps.
The important thing
to know, though,
is that, yes, they are
keys, but they also
declare what type that
can be set against them.
And that's important because it
affects how the data is stored.
So when the attribute
is read internally,
it can affect how the
actual values are read.
And it also affects things
like type conversion.
So the system can actually
convert between types for you.
And because of that we can do
some xmllint-ing based on this.
So if you're using an attribute
with the wrong type of value,
we can put that into lint.
And we can sort
of flag it to you
and make sure you're not going
to shoot itself in the foot.
So these are the
types of format types
that you can put in attributes.
The ones on the are left
are all resource types.
So they directly map
to a resource type
that you can set
in your resources,
so things like fraction,
float, string, blah blah.
The ones on the right are
special in that they are only
used for attributes.
Flag is exactly
what it sounds like.
It's a [INAUDIBLE].
So you can have multiple flags
[INAUDIBLE] against each other.
And then the second is enum,
which is exactly what it is.
It's an enumeration of ints.
So you only get one value back.
And then you've got the last
one, which is reference.
And that's kind of a
catch-all for everything else.
So drawable uses this because
we don't have a drawable type.
But basically it just
points to another resource.
It points to a resource ID.
So how you actually
declare attributes
is like this, using the attr
tag, again, in your resources.
So everything's quite
inside each other.
And here you can see that there
are two things you need to set.
The first of the name.
So this is the actual
declaration for Android
background using the framework.
So it has a name of background.
And then it declares
its type and its format.
It can accept two types,
reference and color.
Reference because it expects
a drawable, and color because,
as we said earlier, it
can do type conversion.
So what will happen is it
can it accept a color int,
like an int value.
And then the system will
automatically change that
into a color drawable for you.
So that's the type conversion
we were talking about earlier.
So all attributes
provided by the framework
are in the Android
schema, which is
why at the top of
all of your layouts
you have to declare
this name space.
Now the name for the namespace,
in this case Android, which is
in bold, is just a convention.
You don't have to use this.
You can name it
whatever you want.
But I'd advise you
to keep using this
because it clearly separates
what are your attributes
and what are
Android's attributes.
You can also declare custom
attributes in your app.
And indeed, you're
probably already using
libraries, which declare
their own attributes.
Now it's important to
know that all attributes
that are declared in your
app-- so even libraries
are in like a global namespace.
Now what that
practically means is
that if two
libraries, basically,
if there are two declarations
of the same attribute
name in your app,
your app won't build,
because you'll get a conflict.
So it's something
to be careful about.
Now as I just mentioned,
any attributes
which are created in your app
or in your app's namespace.
So instead of declaring
the Android namespace,
you declare your app's one.
Now you do that via this syntax.
And you insert
your package name.
Now we know that's
slightly clumsy to use.
So the tools have
a quick shortcut.
So instead of actually putting
the slash in your package name,
you just do res-auto, and
it will do all the hard work
for you.
So we've just talked
about what they are.
Now let's talk about
the differences
and how you actually use them.
So themes, now themes are
tied your context, which
is why it takes two methods.
It has two methods
on the context,
one called setTheme,
which takes a resource
ID pointing to a style.
Now there's one
thing to note here.
It's a kind of a badly named
method in that it doesn't set.
It applies.
So you'll already have a
theme on your activity.
And then when you call this
method, it will apply on top.
It doesn't actually wipe
anything out underneath.
And then you have
a getTheme, which
will return an instance
of the current theme.
Now you'll typically set themes
in your Android manifest.
So you'll set it in the
Android tag or whatever it is.
Now internally all
that does is, just
before your
[INAUDIBLE] is called,
it will call setTheme for you.
So it's exactly the same API as
what the framework are calling.
Now themes don't actually
really do anything.
I like to think of them
as like big configuration
stores for everything else.
So let's take a look
at some of the things
which are actually in
there and what kind
of configuration things are on.
So the first thing is
default widget styles.
So when you create a widget
in your layout, say EditText,
it will have a default
style applied to it.
And the way it finds out
what that default style is
is from your theme.
Now each different widget
has a different attribute
for its default style.
EditText is called
at editTextStyle.
Text view is called
textViewStyle.
You get the idea.
But yeah, so that's
the default style.
We have some color values.
The ones you'll probably
mostly use are for text colors.
So there's textColorPrimary,
secondary, tertiary.
Alan's going to talk
more about these later,
but there are others.
Text appearance
styles, so again Alan
is going to talk about
text appearances.
But they're basically mini
styles which affect only text.
Now this is where I think the
bulk of stuff is in themes.
And that is window
configuration values.
So when your activity is
created, and your dialog,
a window is created
for you internally.
And that is where your
whole View hierarchy sits.
And above that is a
lot of framework stuff.
So if you're using
an action bar,
it will inject a load of
views for the action bar.
And this is-- so all
the configuration
values in your theme
is how that affects it.
So there's also stuff for
like window transitions
and all that kind of things.
Then we have some drawables.
Wouldn't it nice if
we provided some sort
of off-the-shelf handy
drawables to use.
And we do.
The most important, I think,
is selectableItemBackground.
That will give you a
really nice drawable
to use as a background for a
view, like applicable view.
And it will like
give you highlights.
So on Material and above, it
will give you like a ripple.
Before that it's kind
of like a state list.
And then lastly is a section
we call Themeception.
Alan's going talk
more about this later.
But it's-- basically there are
certain components when created
are allowed to
override the theme.
And they'll pick it
out from your master
theme in your activity.
Right, so that's
themes out of the way.
Let's talk about styles.
Now styles do a lot.
They're the things that
do the bulk of the work
when styling your views.
They're really handy for
the sort of decomposition
of common stylings.
They can reuse stuff
across different views.
So let's take a
look at an example.
So here we have a view.
And we want to reuse
this background tag.
Now this is kind of
a trivial example.
Because you're only
reusing one thing.
And you wouldn't
usually do this.
You'd probably
reuse three or four.
But it's a bit of an unwieldy
example if we do more.
So we're going to reuse
this background tag.
So here's our style for it.
So we'll create a style.
And then we'll put an
item in there pointing
to the attribute, so the name.
And then we'll put
our value within it.
Now each attribute you set
goes into the item tag.
Then once we've done that,
we can go back to our layout
and swap the Android background
and replace it with a style
tag pointing to the style.
Now if you've got more
items in that style,
they will be applied too.
A bit of a pro-tip for
you, Android Studio
does that whole flow for
you in a really nice way.
If you go to the
Design tab when you're
looking at a layout and
right click on a View,
go Refactor, Refactor Style.
It gives you a nice
little UI where
you can like pull out attributes
and put them into a style.
It will do it all for you.
But the other really
good thing it does
is that it will try and find
other views in your layout
and then automatically
reuse the style.
It's really cool.
So hopefully now you
now know the difference
between themes and styles.
So let's have a look
at the intricacies
of actually creating them.
So one of the things that
you can do with styles
is that they
support inheritance.
Now themes and
styles can inherit
from each other, which
is handy for when you're
creating derivative styles.
And you'll see
examples in a minute.
Important thing to know is
that they overlay each other.
There are a couple of ways
of implementing inheritance
in styles.
The first is implicitly,
using the dot notation.
So the parent here would
be Widget.Material.Button.
So it's the style before
the proceeding dot.
You can also do it explicitly.
And that's done
through the parent tag.
So here we've got a style
called MyButtonStyle.
And it sets an explicit parent.
And as you'd guess, the
parent is what you've set.
Now there's a small gotcha in
that the explicit way always
wins over the implicit.
So we've got style here,
which is using both dot
notation, as in the name.
But also has a parent tag.
And the explicit
version always wins.
Now the really powerful
thing when using styles
is that you can reference
values from your theme.
And that's done in attribute
thing we talked about earlier.
So here we go back
to our style that we
created, which sets the
backgrounds in my_drawable.
And instead of
using that we want
to use the
selectibleItemBackground, which
we talked about earlier,
which is that nice clickable
highlight.
So this is the theme
that's actually used.
So let's break that
down a little bit.
Because it looks a
little bit alien.
So let's break it down.
First thing is
the question mark.
Now that denotes
that we are going
to be doing a theme lookup.
The second bit,
the Android colon
is the namespace we're
going to be looking up.
So the name of-- the namespace
that the attribute is in.
So if you're using
a custom attribute,
you can put whatever
namespace you're setting to.
Then we have attr slash.
Now that denotes
the type of thing
we're going to be looking up.
Now in true Android
fashion, we only
have one type, which is attr.
So you can actually omit this,
which you'll see in a minute.
And then we have
the last bit, which
is the actual name of
the attribute we're
going to be looking up.
Now as I said, the
type is optional.
Which is probably where
you've seen this syntax.
So the attr slash is omitted.
It works the same.
So now we're going to
hand it over to Alan
to go through Theme.Material.
ALAN VIVERETTE: Thanks, Chris.
So Chris just gave
you the technical side
of what is a theme?
What is a style?
And how do we create them?
So we're going to go hands
on with some of the material
styles to learn what we have
as a base of building blocks
for our own styles and how we
can apply these in practice.
So first we have themes.
Themes in Android are
prefixed with Theme dot.
In Material it's Theme.Material.
So everyone should be
familiar with these.
We've got the
Material Dark theme.
We have themes that have window
attributes for dialogues.
And of course we
have themes that
do some special things
like give you a dark action
bar on top of a light theme.
And if you look at the actual
framework definitions of these,
it's just a huge bag of
attributes for colors, window
attributes, things like that.
We also have overlay themes.
So these are themes that
define a subset of values
that, as Chris
mentioned, get applied
on top of your existing theme.
So for example, Material.Light
contains only the colors
relevant for a light theme.
It's not going to change any
of your window attributes.
For people who are developing
for older platforms,
you may have noticed
on API 21 and 22,
that if you set a color
accent in your theme
and then you open a
dialogue, on API 21 and 22
you're still going to get teal.
Unless you explicitly go
and create a dialog theme
that redefines
your accent color.
In API 23, we added a
dialog overlay theme.
This only redefines the window
attribute specific to dialogs.
It gets applied on top
of your activity theme.
So the host activity
that creates the dialog,
we apply window
attributes on top of that.
So your color accent,
anything else you've set
gets propagated to dialogs
in API 23 and above.
Overlay themes look like this.
Again, it's just a
subset of the things that
would have been defined
in the overall material
light, or dark, or
whatever themes.
You can create these
yourselves very easily.
And then just use
Theme.applyStyle or setTheme
in your activity.
Material theme spec also defines
a number of text appearances.
So for larger text you change
the opacity a little bit.
For buttons you
may set all caps.
These are prefixed
with TextAppearance.
In material,
TextAppearance.Material.
At the XML level,
these are just sets
of attributes specific to text.
And these are either
defined in your theme
with TextAppearance
small attribute.
Or you can apply them
directly to a text view using
the android:textAppearance
attribute.
So this is just going to
apply a set of text attributes
to style your text.
We also have a number of
default widget styles.
So these are prefixed
with Widget.Material.
They are going to
implement things
that you'll recognize
from the Material spec.
So for example, in
API 24, Android N,
we've added a SeekBar.Discrete.
Widget.Material.
SeekBar.Discrete, which is going
to give you these little tick
marks along each progress
point in your seek bar.
You can check out API
demos for a longer example
of some of the
different variations
that we have on widget styles.
But these you can apply to
your widgets with the style
attribute So
style=SeekBar.discrete will
give you these dots.
And these are just
sets of attributes
that are going to provide
defaults for your views.
So for example, the
SeekBar Discreet
has implicit inheritance
from the Material SeekBar.
And we just redefine tick mark
so that we get those drawables
at each progress point.
So while we're
here, anybody who's
really dug into
the material theme
may have noticed
something unusual
about our widget styles.
And this is that the light
themes and dark themes
are identical.
So our light themes
typically just inherit
directly from the default themes
and don't redefine anything.
But under different
parent themes--
so if your activity
is light or dark--
you're still going to get
correctly colored widgets.
How do we do that?
Well, as Chris
mentioned, we have
colors defined by the themes.
And we're going to use
these in the widgets.
So this allows really
high level styling
of what things look like.
Everybody should be
familiar with color accent
from Material.
This gives you a
little pop of color
that shows up in various places.
For the background
of Button.Color,
the foreground of borderless
colored buttons, radio buttons,
etc.
And one example of
how to implement this.
So for the colored button
that we just showed,
we have a background that
points to a drawable.
In that drawable,
which is just a ripple
wrapping a rounded rect
shape-- we actually
don't use P and Gs
anymore-- we have a tint.
And that tint points
to a color state list.
And that color state
list has and enabled
and a disabled state.
The enabled state
points to color accent.
So when you see
that colored button,
the default color is
going to be color accent
tint on a white shape drawable
wrapped with a ripple.
So let's talk a little bit
more about theme colors.
We also have foreground
and background colors.
So these are going to be white
and black or black and white,
respectively, for the
light and dark themes.
And what good does
this actually do us?
You may not be using
flat black or flat white
in your application a lot.
Well, let's take the
switch for an example.
So the switch has a couple
of different colors.
And we could have
defined theme attributes
for switch foreground,
switch background.
And they're all basically just
variations on white or black.
So let's dig into
the XML for this.
The switch track is defined
as a rounded rect shape.
Again, we don't really use PNGs.
And it points to a color
state list for its tint.
In the enabled
state, this is going
to be a dropped alpha--
sorry, in the disabled state,
this is going to inherit
the disabled alpha
from the theme, which varies
based on light or dark theme.
And it's going to use
the foreground color.
So in the dark theme, you have a
dropped alpha version of white.
This is applied on top
of a rounded rec that
already has a dropped opacity.
So we're going to end
up with everything
being a slight variation
on the foreground color.
And you can very easily use
this in your own widgets
to get something that's going to
be consistent with your theme.
We also have text colors,
as Chris mentioned.
So we have a primary
text color, which
is used to provide very
high contrast for things
that the user needs to be
looking at immediately.
We have secondary
text color, which
is just a dropped opacity.
And these are going to
follow the material specs.
So I believe 84%
and 56% opacity.
And they're going to
follow the theme colors.
We also have inverse
versions of these,
which we don't use so much
on the platform anymore.
But if you're going to
be displaying content
against, say, your accent
color, text primary inverse
or secondary inverse is
a great way to do that.
We also have color accent
primary and primary dark,
which we added in Material,
and are going to provide
your branding colors.
So if you're pulling in color
accent, you get that color pop,
you'll probably
want to use a white
or use colored primary
inverse on top of that.
So in a light theme,
you'll have a dark accent.
In a dark theme you'll
have a light accent.
And you can pull these into your
drawables and your color state
lists.
We also have color control
normal and activated.
Control normal is great.
And I really recommend everybody
use this if you have icons.
So for example,
check boxes are going
to use color control
normal by default.
If you're pulling an
icon into your action bar
and you tint it with
color control normal,
it's going to be the
exact right opacity.
And the number of times
that I've seen applications
where the toolbar icons are
different by like 5% alpha,
it kills me every time.
So please use color control
normal for your icons.
So looking at an
example from API demos,
you can probably guess how a
lot of these widgets are set up.
So we have compound buttons,
which is text color primary.
We have that switch
text right below it,
which is text color secondary.
We have the accent color in the
activated state for our check
boxes and radio buttons.
And we have the color background
as our overall background,
color background floating
as our card background.
So you can look at a
screen shot of something,
or look at an application,
and probably guess
where a lot of the
colors are coming from.
Right, so now we
have an overview
of what's available
to us and how
these are used to build the
framework themes and styles
and how we can apply
these to our applications.
And these are very
powerful tools in Android.
And theme attributes
are especially powerful
starting in API 21.
So starting in API 21, you can
use color state lists and theme
attributes to tint
your drawables.
So you can specify
color control highlight
for your ripple, which is
what we have is the default.
And you can specify
ColorStateList as a tint
or as a color for
XML defined shapes.
So if you'd like to step away
from using PNGs all the time,
maybe you have a bunch
of different PNGs
for different colors of
states, you can just directly
put a ColorStateList in.
And when you press a button,
you'll get a different color.
ColorStateLists support
theme attribute starting
in the next API version, 22.
This means that you can start
pulling in the foreground
color, the accent
color, setting the alpha
to match the theme in your
ColorStateLists, which
is going to again,
help you step away
from having drawable
selectors or individual PNGs
for all of your assets.
AppCompat also supports
ColorStateLists.
Starting in version 24, you
can use AppCompatResources,
which is going to provide
an alternate inflation
path that can read
theme attributes
from your ColorStateList XML.
It does this
automatically internally.
And you can do this at run
time for specific XML files.
We also support view tinting.
So what this means is, for
views that own drawable assets,
things like the thumb in a
switch, the track in a progress
bar, you can tint these either
from layout XML or at run-time
using some accessor methods.
So, for example, Switch
has a thumb and a track.
And because it's a view,
it also has a background.
All of these have
separate XML attributes
that you can use to set a tint.
These can take theme attributes.
These can take ColorStateLists.
In API 22, they can
take ColorStateLists
of theme attributes.
This is a really powerful way
to tint just a one off somewhere
within your layout.
So you need this
switch to be red,
you can make it
red really easily.
You need it red with
a disabled state,
you can set a ColorStateList.
As I mentioned, we have a
bunch of text appearances
in the Material style.
These are just bags
of text attributes.
So you can apply these
to your text views using
Android:textAppearance.
And you can reapply
these at run time,
which is actually something kind
of unusual for Android styles.
So for most views, styles get
applied once at inflation time.
For text views, you
can restyle them
at run time, whenever
you need to, using
the setTextAppearance, which
takes a style, which should be
a textAppearance
or something that
inherits from a textAppearance.
It just defines a set
of text attributes.
All right, so we've
learned some cool things
about what's available to us
for creating styles and creating
theme drawables.
How can we apply this to
do something kind of cool?
Well, we introduced
the day night theme
in the support library.
And this is something that
we've supported in the platform
for actually quite a long time.
So day night is implemented
as a resource qualifier.
This has existed since API 8.
Starting in API 23,
this is something
that any application can
toggle through UI Mode Manager.
So if you write an
application and you
want to toggle the global
state of day night mode,
you just go into
UI Mode Manager,
and you can set a Night mode.
When that changes, it's going
to be treated as a configuration
change like you would
have for changing device
orientation, which adds the
landscape resource qualifier.
So this is going
to really simplify
swapping light and dark
resources if your user either
prefers dark or if you want to
set it up for automatic, where
at night time maybe your
user will see a dark theme,
and daytime they'll
see a light theme.
So the actual implementation
of this relies on inheritance.
So we specify a DayNightTheme.
And we have the same name
in both our values and Night
qualified values directories.
And the only difference
is the parent
that we're inheriting from.
So under not Night or
the default qualifier,
we're going to inherit
from Theme.Material.Light.
And under the Night
qualifier, we're
going to inherit from
the dark Material theme.
Now the magic here is that when
we have this resource qualifier
change, the
application's going to go
through a lifecycle event.
We'll get in on
configuration change.
And we're going to
reload our theme
using this new parent,
Which means everything
that we inflate is going to
have different theme colors.
Now you can also
define explicit colors.
So if you want to have
a hard-coded color
and define that differently
under Night or Not Night,
you can do that.
But it's easier to
rely on theme colors.
So the end result of this
is that because everything
gets inflated
against your theme,
and we're using a
different parent,
you're going to get either
dark or light resources.
And in custom
widgets that you've
made, where you're
using theme attributes,
you're just going
to automatically get
the right colors.
So you don't have
to do a lot of work
to switch between implementing
a light and a dark theme.
As Chris demonstrated in our
What's New in Support Library
talk yesterday, this has
been back ported to API 14
through AppCompat.
So if you want to implement a
light or dark, light and dark
theme support in your
application, super easy.
Most of the work is
already done for you.
You just need to add
a little switch that
will toggle Night mode.
Right, so using
themes and attributes
can help simplify switching
the visual presentation
of your application.
But what if you
want to change just
a small portion of presentation
in your application?
So we know that Theme.Material
can make your application look
dark.
We know that
Theme.Material.Light can make
your application look light.
But what if you want to have
something like a dark action
bar, but the rest of your
application be light?
Well, there's one way
you could do this.
You could use the Light
Activity Light theme
and then just specify
everything in your action bar
manually to be dark.
That's a little complicated.
So maybe instead we'll
have a dark theme.
And we'll just manually
specify everything
in our activity,
all of our content,
to be a different color.
That ends up being
really, really tricky.
So please don't do that.
Don't hard code text colors.
So there's an easier way, and
that is through overlay themes
and specifying
themes on portions
of your view hierarchy.
And this is what we do with
the DarkActionBar theme.
So we actually
redefine the theme
that's used for the toolbar
section of your application.
So everybody recalls
we have overlay themes.
We have light theme that
pulls in light colors.
We have dark theme that
pulls in dark colors.
And these are implemented using
the android:theme attribute
from XML.
So this gets picked up
by the layout inflator.
And it's going to replace,
or overlay, the theme
used to inflate a subsection
of your view hierarchy.
And the actual
implementation here
is pulling the theme
attribute from your XML
and then applying that as a
context theme wrapper, which
is exactly what it sounds like.
We take your inflation
context, and we're
going to apply a
theme on top of that.
We're then going to inflate
all of the child content
against this new
wrapped context.
So what you will
get is effectively
the dark theme in
the section of layout
that has Android theme equals
dark and light everywhere else.
The actual
implementation of this
relies on the default
layout that we
provide for an activity
that has an action bar.
So if you dig into some of
the XML files in the Android
framework, Screen
Action Bar is what
we inflate if you've requested
an action bar in your activity.
And we're going to set the
Android theme attribute
to inherit from the action
bar theme attribute defined
in your theme, which has
attribute and theme a lot
of times, which is why we
call this Themeception.
So we're going to pull
in the dark theme on top
of the light activity theme.
We've defined Action Bar theme
in the DarkActionBar theme
as Material.Dark.ActionBar.
This is the dark overlay, which
pulls in the dark theme colors.
It switches the text foreground
and background colors.
And Action Bar sets up a
couple of special things
for displaying the, let's see,
accent color in your toolbar.
But the important part is that
we're pulling in dark colors
on top of your base light theme.
We also redefine
the pop up theme,
so that you get a light pop
up on top of a dark action
bar on top of a light activity.
So we have three themes
at work here, all
overlayed atop one another.
We also support Android.Theme
through the AppCompat library.
So this is going to work
all the way back to API 7
for XML that gets inflated
throughout AppCompat.
An inheritance of
the parent theme
is going to work on
API 11 and above.
And what this means is that
if you put Android:theme
in your XML, on API 7 we will
apply it to that view only.
On API 11 and above
we will apply it
to all of the views
that are inflated
as a child of that view.
Right, now Chris is going to
cover some common mistakes
that developers make when
using themes and styles.
CHRIS BANES: Thanks, Alan.
So as Alan said,
we're now going to go
through some of the
things we see quite a lot,
both in Google Apps
and also externally
on things like stack overflow.
Now hopefully I'll be able
to stop repeating myself.
Because we see this a lot.
And we always say
the same thing.
So the first thing we're
going to go through
is using the incorrect
style parent.
So it's easier if we
go through an example
and show you what
this can actually do.
So here we have an EditText.
Well, we have multiple EditText.
And what we want to do, we want
to make every EditText have
a different font.
The medium font, but
it could be anything.
So what we're going to do, we're
going to change the default
style for EditText.
And then set it to
have a medium font.
So here we have example,
and here's our style.
So, our style here, and
it's MyEditTextViewStyle.
It could be whatever you want.
But it sets one thing,
which is font family.
And that's sets it to medium
Now once you've done that, we'll
then reference it in our theme
so it gets picked up as default.
And then you run your app,
and you see this.
Suddenly all of your
EditTexts have gone.
You've lost all your styling.
They're no longer editable.
But you have changed
the font to medium.
Now the reason why
this happened is
that you didn't set a
parent on the style.
And what that happens is
that you no longer pick up
all of the system defaults.
So you no longer get
the background, the fact
that it's editable, all sorts of
weird and random things, which
are in the style.
So the way to fix it is you
just set the correct parent.
Now the best way of finding
out what a parent is is
just look at the theme
you're inheriting from.
So if you're using
Theme.Material,
just go into it.
It is big.
It's about 200 lines-ish.
But it's all quite
nicely spaced out.
They're all grouped together.
It's not too hard to read.
And suddenly once you've fixed
it, it all looks good again.
Now this is quite a
technical mistake.
You're all ready
going to mistake this
if you're kind of
writing custom views.
But it's the difference between
default style attr and default
style res.
Now there are two places
where you'll use this.
The first is the 4-arg
constructor on View.
Now that was added in API
21, so I doubt many of you
are using it.
But the main place
you're going to use this
is in obtainStyledAttributes.
And that is the way you actually
read attributes in Views.
So here you can
see at the bottom,
the last appearances are default
style attr and default style
res.
And the problem is that default
style attr should always
point to an attr.
So the default style
attr should point
to an attribute in your theme
to pick the default style from.
Now the last one,
default style res
should point to an actual
resource, so an actual style
resource.
In this point, R.style.Widget
blah blah blah.
Now if you mix them up,
basically thing stop working.
Now following on
from that, there's
some intricacies in how
obtainStyledAttributes actually
works.
And it's to do with
the order preference
of how it reads an attribute.
So when you're trying to
read a set of attributes,
this is the order
it goes through.
So the first thing it
looks for is the value
in your attribute set.
Now that, the
attribute set is what
contains all the
attributes, which
are set on you actual layouts.
So if you have a
layout and you've
set Android background on
it, it will be contained
in the attribute style.
The second thing it looks
for is the same value
within any explicit style.
So if you're use a style
tag pointing to a style,
it will then look
for it in there.
The first thing it looks for
is in the default style res.
So that's in the actual concrete
pointer to a default style.
Lastly it looks at the
attribute of the default
style in your theme.
And then finally it looks at
the base value in the theme.
Now please don't rely on this.
Because it leads on to the next
mistake, which is using view
attributes in themes.
So this is a mistake, which
actually someone on our team
made recently.
So here we have a theme.
And we've set the Android
background tag on it.
Now Android background
is something
that you'd usually
use in a view.
But here it's set in a theme.
Now going back to the
obtainStyledAttributes bit,
the last thing it looks for is
in the base value of the theme.
Which basically means
that, because you've
set that in your
theme, any view which
doesn't have a background set
in it will then use this value.
Which basically means, if you
set a background in your theme,
let's say it the
color pink, every view
which doesn't have an
explicit background
will have this pink background.
And that's a really big mistake
which you see quite often.
Now we are actually going to
write more of these mistakes
off into a blog post.
So follow us on social,
and we'll post them up.
All right, that's it.
Hopefully you've learned some
stuff about themes and styles.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]